mercredi dernier Agnès LaSalle
professeur d'espagnol au lycée Saint
Thomas d'Aquin de Saint-Jean-de-Luz a
été assassiné dans sa classe par un de
ses élèves
cet acte d'une violence inouïe nous
plonge dans la sidération et dans la
tristesse je vais ici rappeler tout le
soutien de la représentation nationale à
la communauté enseignante et exprimée
nos plus sincères condoléances à la
famille de la victime et à ses collègues
[Applaudissements]
cet événement tragique survient dans un
établissement et dans une ville paisible
mais le contexte général dans lequel
nous vivons où les actes de violence
physique se banalisent parfois sous
l'influence des réseaux sociaux et des
jeux vidéo
contaminent inexorablement tous les
espaces l'école ou s'épanouissent et se
développent nos enfants n'est
malheureusement plus un sanctuaire nos
enseignants sont confrontés au quotidien
à la violence et sont souvent démunis
pour y répondre leur protection doit
être une priorité pour qu'il puisse
exercer leur mission dans la plus grande
sérénité
cet événement tragique pose aussi la
question de la détection et de la prise
en charge des troubles psychologiques au
sein même de l'institution scolaire les
moyens affectés à la médecine scolaire
sont-ils suffisants les psychologues
scolaires sont-ils en capacité d'assurer
un suivi adéquat pour des élèves qui
rencontrent de plus en plus des
difficultés psychologiques surtout
depuis le covid de plus les familles
doivent attendre de longs mois pour
obtenir des soins auprès d'un
professionnel de santé mentale et la
coordination entre les différents
acteurs et souvent difficiles monsieur
le ministre quelle mesure comptez-vous
mettre en oeuvre pour assurer une
meilleure protection de nos enseignants
et pour améliorer la détection et le
suivi des élèves atteints de troubles
psychologiques je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Sarah
elle a écrit secrétaire d'État chargé de
la jeunesse et du service national
universel
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Vincent Bru partez permettez-moi d'abord
de m'associer à votre hommage celui
rendu à la professeur Agnès Lassalle
professeur d'espagnol au sein du lycée
de Saint-Jean-de-Luz qui a été assassiné
mercredi dernier évidemment nous pensons
avec mention avec émotion à sa famille à
ses élèves à ses collègues et à toute la
communauté éducative parce que les
professeurs remplissent ces missions
essentielles d'élever les esprits
d'élever les espérances de transmettre
ses savoirs à chaque fois que l'un
d'entre eux est touché c'est évidemment
un petit bout de nous tous c'est contre
l'école et c'est contre la République
mais vous le savez monsieur le monsieur
le député le ministre de l'éducation
nationale s'est rendu quasi
immédiatement sur place pour pour
soutenir les équipes éducatives
accompagner du secrétaire général de
l'enseignement catholique comme vous le
savez et vous l'avez souligné monsieur
le député l'école elle n'est plus elle
n'est pas hermétique aux problématiques
de notre société
et nous avons le devoir pour autant de
prouver de protéger ce sanctuaire et de
ne pas abandonner l'idée que l'école est
un sanctuaire alors pour cela nous avons
mis en place des plans particuliers de
mise en sûreté qui sont élaborés
conjointement avec les référents de
force de force de l'ordre pour permettre
en cas de danger imminent de pouvoir
l'activer mais le lycée de Saint de
saint Thomas d'Aquin ne connaissait
aucune violence ce lycée avait
évidemment mis en place ce plan de
sûreté mais ça n'a pas permis d'éviter
l'impossible à prévoir et c'était le cas
malheureusement mercredi dernier il y a
des sujets sur lequel nous devons
avancer plus vous les en avez souligné
un certain nombre monsieur le député je
pense évidemment à la santé mentale des
élèves pas pendiaye ministre de
l'éducation nationale et le ministre de
la santé vont accentuer un certain
nombre de parcours je pense évidemment à
mon parcours psy qui renforce le lien
entre les enseignants entre les
enseignants les médecines scolaire et la
médecine de ville monsieur le député il
y a également le recrutement de 20% de
d'infirmiers supplémentaires mais
surtout nous souhaitions saluer le
courage et la dignité de l'équipe
pédagogique du lycée Saint Thomas
d'Aquin je vous remercie